Hey Beth!
Hello!
Erin, it is always lovely to see you.
And you as well, my dear.
Erin, I have a confession to make.
We did another episode where we talked about ilastik and how ilastik is wonderful, all
which is true, but we told people a rule.
And we don't usually tell people rules.
Yeah, we don't.
We don't make rules.
I think we give a lot of guidance, but we were like, we don't usually give rules without
explaining them.
And we were like, you should always use the one pixel brush.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
We kind of mandate that one without explaining it.
Yeah.
So, I figured we should probably explain it.
That would be very nice of us.
But, because it's not always intuitive in ilastik, you know, they make all those gorgeous
brush sizes.
And there are certainly cases where, especially for electron microscopy imaging, you might
use the bigger brush, but for fluorescence imaging and for simple cases, you always
want to avoid what's called overfitting.
And so I thought I would try to give a little bit of a demonstration today about overfitting.
Delightful.
All right.
Let's demonstrate this problem.
So this is actually a Python notebook that I made with a tool called Marimo, which is
one of my new favorite Python tools.
But you don't need to know anything about code to use it.
And we can drop the link in the show notes.
So this is using a fun plug-in for Marimo called drawData.
And it's going to let me literally draw data.
Wow.
I think it's fun.
That sounds a little dangerous.
I mean, great for demonstration purposes, but like, wouldn't it be nice if I could just
trust me, guys?
Well, this is what my pull, this is what it looks like.
I just drew it on the graph.
Use your powers for good, not for evil.
If great power comes great responsibility.
Yes.
So what this widget gives us access to is we can have four different colors of data that
we can draw.
And we can, I've added some stuff here, so we can say that we want to split them into
two different classes.
And we can decide which color of dot goes into the two different classes.
Right now, it's actually doing a surprisingly good job at splitting our two different, we
have green and red in class two and blue and orange in class one.
And it says it's actually doing 65% accurate.
I think that's somewhat because we have these blue dots that are out here by themselves
and we have these green dots that are down here.
I suspect if I draw some blue dots on there, I mean, 50-50 accuracy is the worst you can
do, right?
Because then you're just flipping a coin.
So we wouldn't expect this to get down to zero, but I was surprised it was even getting
much above 50%.
So if I put some blue dots here.
Yeah.
We're trending down and down towards, well, no, now it's actually getting better again.
But you can see that the accuracy for individual points and for the individual classes changes
as I draw data.
So now let's reset and then let's talk about overfitting.
So overfitting is just the idea that if we have multiple things within the data, some
of which are differences we care about and some of which are differences that we don't.
With machine learning, and here we're using a kind of machine learning called random forest,
which is based on decision trees, we can't always control how the machine chooses to
learn.
This is going to be even worse when we get to thinking about things like deep learning.
But the amount of data that a machine learning classifier like a random forest, which is what
ilastik uses sees, is going to essentially determine how important it thinks a particular
kind of data is.
It will learn to cheat if some data is common and some data is rare to only predict the
common data, because it can do really well while ignoring the rare data.
Did that make sense?
I think so.
So we're saying that we can't rephrase this to make sure I've understood.
If we have a situation where there's a super common phenotype and more rare phenotype,
if most of the information it has is about that common phenotype, can't tell it, oh,
go pay more attention to the rare one because that's what we care about finding.
It is in control of what it's paying attention to.
So it may then say, hey, if only 1% of the time is this rare object, I can be 99% accurate
by just calling everything normal.
I'm just never going to find that and I'm doing great.
Yeah.
And I think there's a great way to sort of demonstrate that.
So here I'm just going to draw in a few dots of class one.
I'm going to draw now a bunch of dots from class two right on top of it.
And this is saying that this is 99% accurate.
And that's because if it just guesses two all the time, it's 99% accurate because there's
319 green dots and four blue ones.
Well, we can see that down there.
It's saying the per class accuracy for class C is 100%.
So all it's guessing every single green dot correctly, but the per class accuracy for
class A is zero.
So it is literally finding no blue dots.
Love it.
Beautiful way to cheat there and not helpful to us at all if we care about those blue dots.
So we can even sort of take this a step further where we have our blue dots and we have our
green dots.
And now these are 100% accurate mostly based on X rather than Y, which makes sense.
I've split these on the X axis versus the Y axis.
If we now take a third thing, B, which should be is part of class one.
So it should go into the class A group.
And I just drop a couple little points here.
And I sort of scatter them equally.
Can see as I sort of make them look more like the class C distribution, there's still a
lot more A's than B's.
A, it's still keeping perfect.
And it's still saying that X is by far the most important thing and just the class B is
getting worse and worse and worse.
And then plateauing down at about that 50-50 coin flip because overall there's way more
data in A than B.
I can make B even worse by just sort of adding more and more and more data to A.
I didn't make it worse.
No, I don't understand.
I think just because now it's...
Yeah, I don't actually understand why.
I think because we've now changed our Y distribution.
But you can see how...
But hopefully you can see is that how much data there is is changing the performance
between our ability to sort of say change between two different classes.
If there's tons of data of one kind and very little data of another kind, it makes a big
difference how accurate and how important that other kind becomes.
So how does this relate to ilastik?
Well, it's super tempting in ilastik to take out that really big brush and to make it so
that you have a really big brush where you're covering lots of pixels of an individual cell.
And if you remember back to our episode on ilastik, you might remember when we drew a
lot in the background and we learned a lot about the background.
The background became more confident.
But the actual thing that we were trying to fix there, the error of the background close
to a cell, didn't change at all because we didn't give it any extra information.
Yeah, that makes sense.
So in that case, because it was such a striking thing, we were then able to fix the background
without too much difficulty.
But what we might have accidentally done was say, hey, this part next to the cell is really
unimportant.
Because ilastik uses a really big random forest, it was able to actually figure out, OK, I
have a bunch of pixels that are sort of like, imagine these blue pixels.
We can even actually sort of draw this a little bit more like a cell where if we have a nice
little brush here.
And now we sort of go around.
And our random forces deep enough because these are really simple to say, all right,
if it's within these two things and not across this other thing, and it's doing mostly X
rather than Y, because we have this sort of blue class here.
But the more pixels that we sort of put here, the more times that when our random force
decision trees are trying to say, is this from class one or class two, it's going to
mostly end up with pixels from B here.
So now we change the feature importance and we change our ability to change if we actually
want in a new image to be more like class A, it's going to be hard for the 50 pixels
in class A to compete with the 350 pixels here.
So we have to add more pixels and more pixels and more pixels and more pixels when we didn't
actually need that many to get started.
And so we just make annotation take way longer and be harder to do and maybe be impossible
to do when we have super rare classes.
Like if there's something where there are only 50 pixels, we can't just add 500 more
because our data is our data.
So if we make it so that those 50 pixels always matter by having fewer annotations rather
than lots and lots of annotations, we make sure that those 50 pixels always count in
the end.
Yeah, that makes so much sense.
I think, the cash, this makes me think of a couple of important points that are, I don't
know, one thing too that we have to think about in general in science, right, is when
looking at your metrics, make sure your metrics are actually reporting what you think it's
reporting, that here we have this separation maybe absolutely lovely and giving you a very
high accuracy number.
But again, it could be not because it's performing well on the thing you care about, it's because
it's performing well on the stuff you don't care about.
And so diving into your per class accuracy rather than your separation accuracy is a super
important and helpful thing to think about when thinking about the metrics for your success
at separating and identifying whatever the objects or classes are that you're trying
to identify.
Yeah.
Now, thinking back to what you said when we were looking at that pipeline where you had
the two different things and you were saying that it was actually the correlation between
the two actually behaved really differently when you masked out things that were supposed
to be similar versus weren't supposed to be similar.
It's not something that you necessarily would have naturally come up with, but there's
always little nuances in what are we actually measuring that make the difference.
And the amount of importance that you give to different parts of the measurement when
we get to classifiers and we get to machine learning and where we don't control who makes
the decision can be really, really the difference between success and failure.
Yeah, absolutely.
All right.
Well, I hope this helped create some intuitions around why it is actually important to use
the number one pixel brush in ilastik as well as just how machine learning works in general.
Absolutely.
This is super helpful.
And I think we'll drop this link in the show notes.
You too can go play with this on your own and explore what happens, develop some of your
own further intuition because this is a great way to help think about this, to help think,
to help practice, to help play.
That's great.
And use your data drawing powers for good, not for evil.
Yes, yes.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
See you next time.
Talk to you later.